my ultimate chicken sandwich super spicy
in my mouth dripping with flavor I'm a
guy I deserve to be satiated no this
vegan chick food I want to eat where I
but you got a problem with that I
want my food made by someone who's not
afraid to offend people including me
well who else is gonna make a chicken
sandwich this delicious people that
aren't racist I don't agree with their
politics but that hot sauce is off the
charts
I want a toothless backwater dude
cooking my sandwich put pickles on the
chicken is that racist I don't even know
what race I am but I do know that this
chicken sandwich is delicious look my
brother is gay so I don't need chikk
klub in front of him just like I asked
him not to kiss his boyfriend in front
of my chicken sandwich I'll text my
buddies be like we gonna get chikk klub
they're like absolutely not and I'm like
solo mission I love Who I am where I'm
from
I just love chick club sandwiches just a
little more chick club marriage between
a man a chicken sandwich we're good
you